[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture le magazine pour
vous informer des actualités culturelles
du département voici le sommaire le
festival de bd est de retour le 9 et 10
octobre au château de buc au programme
des rencontres avec des auteurs et du
dédicace de nombreuses animations autour
de la bd seront aussi organisés
promouvoir le théâtre créatif et
novateur c'est l'objectif du festival de
théâtre de bougival il revient prendre
une trentième édition cette année la
directrice artistique du festival du
festival tiendra donc à en parler sur ce
plateau et puis enfin découvrez notre
top 3 des coups de coeur de cette
rentrée littéraire présenté par le
libraire du pavé du canal de montigny le
bretonneux le festival de bd de but fait
donc sa 28e année les 9 et 10 octobre au
château de buc avec des rencontres et
des auteurs est de nombreuses animations
seront organisées regardez c'est
l'événement culturel phare de la ville
de buc le festival de bd revient les 9
et 10 octobre au château de buc
l'édition 2021 accueille encore cette
année plus d'une cinquantaine d'auteurs
français et internationaux ses fans au
carloni bien sûr barbe rouge celui qui a
fait là comment dire larges affiches
vous avez aussi et xavier et giacometti
qui a fait il ya carré et donc c'est le
l'ouverture kurde ridel régric stedo
failli sont nombreux au programme des
dédicaces des expositions la création
d'une fresque géante participative ou
encore des caricatures même temps qu'on
aime beaucoup puisque un caricaturiste
qui est doux mais qui est vraiment
extrêmement doué qui vient sur enfin
tout le long du festival et qui
caricaturent les gens les services
municipaux de la jeunesse accueilleront
également les enfants ils leur
proposeront des activités en lien avec
la bd nous notre objectif c'est d'avoir
à un public le plus intérêt
générationnel possible les gens qui sont
dans la bd vous verrez il ya des
aficionados qui viennent 24-48 heures
qu'ils dorment dehors pour avoir des
dédicaces mais à trappes et recelant on
développe aussi d'autres publics c'est à
dire le jeune public très important
puisque aujourd'hui il faut savoir que
c'est très difficile d'avoir des auteurs
de n'est-ce donc ça c'est un vrai
travail qu'on mène pour avoir un tiers
du plateau un auteur jeunesse autre
nouveauté cette année deux conférences
seront organisées autour de l'oeuvre
d'edgar jacobs plus de 8000 personnes
sont attendues sur le week end et
d'ailleurs la semaine prochaine émission
spéciale au coeur du festival vous
pourrez la retrouver à mardi prochain à
18h30 se rapprocher de la nature de
redevenir sauvage avec l'exposition
rewind la south side gallery interroge
sur le rapport entre l'homme et la
nature cinq artistes exposent au château
de rochefort en yvelines une trentaine
d'oeuvres sont donc à découvrir le
reportage de mélanie poké et justine
brasil
se poser et bien regarder avec rioual
bernis honneur souhaite vous faire
ralentir pour comprendre ce qu'il se
passe ce qui compose son avocat qui
donne le nom à l'exposition
vraiment c'est aussi un apprentissage de
l'observation parce qu'on a besoin
aujourd'hui le on a un problème avec le
temps on court toujours après le temps
mais on a besoin enfin comble ralentir
pour pouvoir mieux observer pour pouvoir
mieux apprécier ce qui nous entoure
notre relation avec la nature passe
souvent par par une étape d'observation
de connaissances et d'apprentissage ils
sont cinq artistes exposés autour du ray
ensauvagement 3 ar se répondent ils sont
entre designers ou artistes numériques
avec un but mettre en valeur la nature
et le rapport de l'homme avec cette
nature c'est important de recevoir le
regard des autres sur un même point
c'est un rapport évidemment avec
l'abstraction avec chacun chacun son
regard sur sur les choses
et surtout ça réunit des forces on a
besoin de réunir des forces pour pour
qu'un message soit plus fort c'est
important d'avoir différentes versions
sur un même message l'exposition à
l'initiative de bernis honneur veut
amener à une réflexion sur la nature et
sur la vie une réflexion à développer à
travers une trentaine d'oeuvres
d'autres d'autres expositions sont à
retrouver dans les yvelines ces
prochaines semaines au château de
maisons laffitte
il vous reste quelques jours pour
découvrir l'exposition dans les studios
des frères s'héberger célébrités 1940
1977 présente jusqu'au 11 octobre elle
retrace le parcours de ces deux
photographes célèbres du 16 au 24
octobre onze artistes peintres et
sculpteurs exposent à la maison 2
coville à voisins le bretonneux
l'exposition l'étoile dans les yeux
accueillera aussi trois créations
olfactives de l'artiste né karol calves
et enfin isabelle vallereau artiste
peintre présente ses peintures
acryliques à l'office du tourisme de du
pays où d'années jusqu'au 30 octobre
l'occasion de découvrir aussi l'art
pictural et le street art dans toutes
ses formes
cette année le festival de théâtre de
bougival fête ses 30 ans de nombreuses
pièces sont programmées au théâtre du
premier à bougival jusqu'au 10 octobre
prochain florence meyer bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes donc la directrice artistique
du festival
cette manifestation est organisée par la
compagnie g 7 donc vous êtes aussi la
présidente ans et bien d'un petit a fait
tout à fait compagnie créée en 2010 et
qui a repris l'organisation la direction
artistique du festival il ya une
douzaine d'années en 2009 alors dans la
totalité il y a huit spectacles tous
qu'ils sont à découvrir est-ce que vous
pouvez peut-être me parler de la
programmation qui est assez riche tout à
fait on essaie toujours de faire une
programmation variée que ce soit dans
les thèmes drame comédie dramatique
comédie
suspense même souvent
et également parmi eux
choisi parmi les auteurs du très varié
donc là cette année il ya des victor
haïm il ya du hanokh levin il ya du eric
emmanuel schmitt voilà on essaye de
mettre en avant les auteurs
contemporains et on essaye également
généralement de m du classique mais
cette année c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué à organiser forcément à cause
de cette période difficile qu'on a
traversées et si je me trompe pas à
l'issue de chaque représentation il ya
une petite particularité le public est
invité à voter absolument à l'issue du
festival donc le dimanche de clôture
le public décerne son prix et le jury
décerne sont prises également puisque il
ya un jury débat chaque soir à l'issue
de chaque spectacle pour remettre le
prix spécial du jury est également
d'autres prix en fonction de leurs coups
de coeur et pourquoi c'est justement
pour faire interagir le public et
les acteurs et les acteurs c'est ça se
veut un espace de convivialité de
découverte de deux curiosités et donc
c'est important pour les acteurs pour
les metteurs en scène de savoir ce que
le public en a pensé c'est quand même ce
qui est le plus important alors on l'a
dit hier le festival de grougi val
souffle de théâtre de bougival sauf ses
30 bougies c'est finalement un réel
tremplin aussi pour les compagnies je
suppose oui alors on a des compagnies
amateurs et on fait venir on accueille
également de jeunes compagnies
professionnelles qui essayent
effectivement d'avoir une fenêtre une
écoute et ça me fait quand même plaisir
de pouvoir les accueillir de pouvoir les
mettre en lumière alors finalement
quelles sont les évolutions du festival
depuis 30 ans puisque ça fait 30 ans que
ça existe écoutez au départ ce n'était
qu'un festival amateur donc c'est vrai
que l'introduction de jeunes troupes
professionnelles a été un pas en avant
le jury également
a évolué puisque j'essaye on essaye
toujours de faire venir des
professionnels également dans jury un
regard de professionnel sur des troupes
c'est toujours intéressant
et puis
sinon écoutez c'est par rapport à la
qualité je pense des troupes également
qui sont choisis on essaye de de choisir
le gratin du gratin on essaye vraiment
de présenter des spectacles de qualité à
notre public et puis la grande ce qui
est très important également c'est de
voir que le public suit et que petit à
petit le le festival gros si ça c'est
important vous serez là aussi l'année
prochaine normalement so lu ment
valeur au but vous ai noté merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été notre avis
merci elle a 22 ans elle a grandi avec
lui dans les yvelines cela fait dix ans
qu'elle chante maintenant mellon sort
son premier ep nouveaux défis le 13
octobre prochain bixente mais rien sorti
steban à la rencontrer pour nous depuis
et c'est toi et seulement toi mon coeur
bat quand j'entends voir tu es mon
oxygène
mon soleil quand je tapais reçoit
respire je m'éveille c'était un petit
extrait de ses toits la première chanson
écrite par mellon la jeune artiste
yvelinoise sort bientôt son premier rhdp
le 13 octobre donc mon épée qui sort
dans deux semaines et
donc cinq titres le ps appelle nouveaux
défis et
figure un clip aux six heures le 18
parmi les titres représentatifs du
projet le futur clip de thalie et la
chanson éponyme nouveau défi dans cette
chanson basse je pense que c'est un peu
à l'image de ce que je veux transmettre
de manière générale c'est comment j'ai
commencé la musique surtout pour un
premier opus je pense que c'est
intéressant de parler de ça où j'ai
commencé la musique qu'est ce que ça me
procure en fait c'est vraiment des
moments plutôt intime où je me
retrouvais moi même dans ma chambre avec
ma guitare sur mon lit y est voilà c'est
comme ça que ça a commencé c'est le
nouveau défi un ep fruit d'une passion
de longue date pour la chanteuse qui
s'exerce sur son temps laissé libre dans
les études ça fait donc depuis
deux ans en fait que je me suis mis à
vraiment à fond dans la musique mais
sinon j'ai commencé vers l'âge de 11 ans
où j'ai commencé à jouer de la guitare
pour m'accompagner au chant sur des
petites chansons voilà j'ai commencé
dans ma chambre à 36 mois une passion
que mélo ne vit pas que dans son studio
puisqu'elle monte aussi sur scène elle a
chanté notamment aux dernières fêtes de
la musique de verneuil gars lui ou
encore ou dans
la rentrée littéraire elle lancé dans
les librairies yvelinoise cette année
elle est assez éclectique aux pavés du
canal à montigny le bretonneux
découvrez les trois coups de coeur des
libraires pour cette rentrée
[Musique]
je voulais vous présenter un délit qui
m'a le plus ému et plus emballés de
cette rentrée littéraire la jeune fille
qu'on appelle un de tanguy viel qui est
un livre qui m'a vraiment bouleversée
l'histoire de max qui est le chauffeur
d'un maire d'une petite ville l'otan au
bord de mer qui va demander en fait à
celui ci s'il peut trouver un boulot et
un logement pour sa fille laura le maire
va accepter elle va trouver donc une un
logement un boulot qui est pas forcément
des plus glorieux et puis surtout il va
demander en fait une certaine faveur
alors à et laura elle va se sentir
obligé d'accepter un roman excellemment
bien écrit fort qui laisse pas indemne
je présente la carte postale à un roman
d'anne berest l'autrice va faire le
déroulé de la vie de ses ancêtres les
grands oncles et tantes qui ont été
déportés à auschwitz on part d'un point
de départ qui est une carte postale où
les noms de ses grand oncles et tantes
et de leurs parents sont notés et qui
arrive dans la boîte aux lettres
familial ça va devenir une sorte de
quête perpétuelle du sens et de son
récit familial puisque en fait elle
n'avait aucune idée de ce qui s'était
passé une recherche personnelle très
très forte émouvant et touchant jusqu au
bout
tu représentes trou story un roman
américain de quatre petits qui se lit
comme un très bon polar deux époques
99-2000
19,99 on va suivre une bande de jeunes
qui ont 17 ans le but dans leur vie
c'est de faire des soirées les plus
folles possible les plus dingues et puis
un soir il y en a deux qui raccompagne
une jeune fille chez elle
je suis et commettre zerka la fumée elle
a bu elle est quasiment pas consciente
on ne sait pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé mais par contre qu'on égalise les
deux garçons reviennent ils sont
titillés par les autres de la bande
forcément il s'est passé quelque chose
on fait un bond de 20 ans dans le temps
et là on reprend certains personnages
qu'on a vu au début et notamment cette
jeune fille et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qu'est ce que c'est c'est paroles
lancées en l'air ont eu comme impact sur
leur vie et sur ses vingt ans passés
c'est absolument génial moi je suis un
roman qui marquait le troisième sont
formidables
et c'est la fin de ses études culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine bonne soirée sur 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]